müssen wir frieren wenn putin und den
gashahn zudreht vor allem im winter sind
wir bislang auf den import von gas
angewiesen deshalb fragen wir woher
kommt unser erdgas was ist energie und
ist das eine alternative für uns
noch bekommen wir den großteil unseres
erdgases aus russland
außerdem beliefern uns noch norwegen und
die niederlande
eine mögliche alternative wenn das
russische gas wegfällt lng liquefied
natural gas verflüssigtes erdgas das
nicht über die pipelines transportiert
werden muss sondern auf dem seeweg nach
europa kommt
der weg von der förderung beispielsweise
in den usa bis zur einspeisung in das
deutsche gasnetz ist lang technisch
anspruchsvoll und braucht viel energie
das geförderte erdgas das hauptsächlich
aus methan besteht wird extrem
heruntergekühlt bei minus 162 grad
celsius ändert es sein zustand von
gasförmig zu flüssig
der vorteil das volumen verringert sich
um das rund 600 fache
verpackt in stark isolierten allen die
tanks sind damit große mengen gas
transportierbar ein großer tanker kann
mit nur einer lieferung eine großstadt
wie beispielsweise mainz fast ein jahr
lang versorgt
am zielort fließt das lng in speziellen
terminals an land oder auf dem wasser
zum schluss muss das verflüssigte erdgas
wieder umgewandelt und ins gasnetz
eingespeist werden
weltweit verkaufen 18 länder lng als
anbieter für den deutschen markt werden
vor allem die usa und katar gehandelt
deutschland selbst verfügt momentan noch
nicht über eigene lng terminals doch die
direkten eu nachbarländer belgien
frankreich und die niederlande haben
seit jahren welche an die deutschland
auch angebunden ist
trotzdem plant die regierung eigene
terminals in brunsbüttel stade und
wilhelmshaven
doch der bau dauert zwei bis fünf jahre
je nach standort experten kritisieren
den neubau der heimischen anlagen denn
schon jetzt sind die eu terminal zu
nicht mal einem drittel ausgelastet aber
langfristig könnten die neuen lng
terminals bundesregierung auch genutzt
werden um klimafreundlichen wasserstoff
zu lagern
insgesamt ist der einsatz von allen die
schon seit jahrzehnten umstritten die
verflüssigung benötigt sehr viel energie
und die langen transportwege per schiff
verursachen erhebliche mengen an
treibhausgasemissionen
die herstellungskosten sind mindestens
dreimal so hoch über erdgas aus der
klassischen pipeline tendenz steigend
was passiert also wenn plötzlich kein
gas mehr aus russland kommt mit dem
moment kann deutschland auf große schuss
erdgas verzichten es braucht jedoch eine
langfristige lösung raus aus der
abhängigkeit von einem großlieferanten
und hin zu verschiedenen anbietern und
unterschiedlichen energiequellen vor
allem klimafreundlichen der import von
lg kann deshalb nur eine übergangslösung
sein ein erster schritt in die
unabhängigkeit von frust
[Musik]